makeup artists are often the unsung
heroes of horror movies from classic
monsters to Modern Terrors you won't
believe what these creepy characters
look like behind their masks
although writer Clive Barker didn't name
the lead cenobites Pinhead in his novel
The Hellbound heart the character's
distinctive appearance earned him the
nickname that stuck throughout the
Hellraiser series ever since Barker
adapted his own story to the screen in
1987 English actor Doug Bradley has
become synonymous with the soul
harvesting Pinhead
[Music]
we have such sights to show you
Bradley is part of a special group of
horror actors who have played their
haunting characters at least six times
in a row he's accompanied by Tobin Bell
as jigsaw Warwick Davis is the
leprechaun Brad Dourif is Chucky
Christopher Lee is Dracula and Robert
Englund as Freddy Krueger but he's also
developed a somewhat complicated
relationship with the franchise Bradley
opted not to return for 2011's
Hellraiser Revelations and The Saga
seems to have moved on without him
2018's Hellraiser judgment marked the
second installment to feature a
different actor under the makeup and
2022's Hellraiser reboot changed things
up by casting Pinhead as a woman still
Bradley will always be Pinhead to us and
we have to think that the majority of
franchise fans agree
Toby Hooper's 1974 horror flick the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre spawned several
kooky and bizarre sequels but the
original is notable for how much it
stood out from other genre entries from
the era heavily inspired by the horrific
true story of Ed Gein Leatherface got
his name from his revolting headpiece
made of human skin while plenty of
people have picked up the chainsaw since
we'll always remember Gunner Hansen for
his original and only portrayal of the
role Hansen set the standard for how to
properly play a chainsaw wielding Maniac
utilizing mannerisms that have been
repeated time and time again in the
character's other appearances fans of
the B-movie mosquito will also recognize
Hansen as one of its main characters who
actually uses a chainsaw to fight off
enormous blood-sucking bugs Hansen
turned down a number of later
opportunities to play terrifying bad
guys opting instead to focus on his
passion for writing eventually Hanson
returned to Hollywood accepting roles
and horror outings like swarm of the
snake at sadly though Hanson succumbed
to pancreatic cancer in 2015 at the age
of 68. Ridley Scott's alien
revolutionized both the science fiction
and horror movie genres in 1979 when
pre-production began no one knew who was
going to be cast as the film's titular
monster but eventually Ridley Scott was
introduced to Nigerian design student
Balaji badejo badejo's lanky frame and
near seven foot tall height would help
convince viewers that the film's monster
was not just a guy in the suit but an
extraterrestrial killing machine you
still don't understand what you're
dealing with
perfect
organism
badejo only played the alien in the
first film of the franchise but still
left a heavy impression future alien
installments used puppetry and CGI to
render their aliens making potatoes
xenomorpha curious yet uniquely
threatening Oddity badejo ended up doing
an amazing job to help sell the illusion
and the xenomorph would go on to become
one of Hollywood's most fearsome and
Unforgettable sci-fi monsters sadly
badejo's alien Legacy would long outlive
him he was only 39 when he passed away
from sickle cell anemia in 1992.
originally Jean-Claude Van Damme was
cast to play the predator in the 1987
action flick of the same name
unfortunately the bulked out appearance
of star Arnold Schwarzenegger and the
rest of the cast made Van Damme seem way
too small for the role despite how
amazing it would have been to see his
predator's kung fu skills Van Damme was
scrapped in favor of Kevin Peter Hall
who also starred as the Towering Title
Character in Harry and the Hendersons
the same year when you've got guys like
Jesse The Body Ventura and Carl Weathers
walking around a jungle you're going to
want to make your movie monster a true
Behemoth and not be 5 foot 10 muscles
from Brussels thankfully Hall's tall
frame made for a perfect predator in
both the 1987 original and its 1990
sequel Predator 2 the year after the
sequel's release Hall passed away at The
Tragically young age of 35 his life and
career cut short by aids-related
pneumonia
John Carpenter's low budget 1978 slasher
classic Halloween helped pave the way
for a generation of Unforgettable
Killers with the film's lumbering silent
psychotic villain and future franchise
star Michael Myers Carpenter added a
heavy psychological aspect to the killer
that we hadn't seen since Norman Bates
decades prior and envisioned the film's
location fictional Haddonfield Illinois
as a typically idyllic suburb that
turned unspeakably creepy after sunset
on October 31st after donning the mask
in the first movie Nick Castle's
performances the shape would be imitated
for years to come he went on to enjoy a
varied career too he co-wrote
Carpenter's dystopian action flick
Escape From New York helped write the
story for Steven Spielberg's hook and is
directed an assortment of movies that
includes the Last Starfighter and The
Boy Who Could Fly 40 years after making
Horror history Castle came full circle
agreeing to reprise his role as Michael
Myers in the 2018
Halloween sequel how could we assemble a
list like this without including the man
of our dreams as much as Jackie Earl
Haley chewed the scenery in the 2010
remake of a Nightmare on Elm Streets
only one actor's name truly resonates
with horror movie nightmares Robert
England horror fans got to watch England
wield the bladed glove for nearly two
decades as he embodied the Twisted
character of Freddy Krueger over the
course of eight films he even got his
own anthology horror series The aptly
named Freddy's nightmares which ran for
two seasons there's no denying that
Freddy is one of the most recognizable
horror icons out there sure his Antics
became a lot sillier as the years went
by but Wes Craven's New Nightmare was a
proper return to form for the
supernatural slasher maybe someday
England will Don the Fedora sweater and
bladed glove one last time for a final
trip down Elm Street until then we can
only dream about it
miss me
yes it's true lots of people have played
Jason Voorhees we've seen the character
go through some dramatic changes over
the years he wasn't even the main killer
in the first Friday the 13th movie and
he didn't start wearing his iconic
hockey mask until the third a whopping
10 actors have played the character so
far but we'd have to choose Kane hotter
as the definitive Jason while he didn't
even sign on to the series until Friday
the 13th Part 7 the new blood hotter's
role helped bring Jason into a new age
of slasher flicks and made him the
hulking Unstoppable Menace that we all
love and remember he's also had the most
experience playing Jason as nearly every
movie prior to part 7 had someone
different in the part donning the mask
for four films the new blood Jason Takes
Manhattan Jason Goes to Hell the final
Friday and Jason X hotter remains a
horror heavyweight champion in our books
Hodder isn't done with Jason yet either
he did motion capture work for Friday
the 13th the game offering fans a chance
to be part of the action for a whole new
series of Thrills
if you've seen a film by director James
1 chances are you've probably spied
composer Joseph bashara's name amongst
the credits his scores appear in
Insidious The Conjuring Insidious
Chapter 2 The Conjuring 2 Aquaman and
malignant he's also provided musical
stylings for other films in The
Conjuring Universe from Annabelle to the
curse of La Llorona but look closely and
you'll notice that bashara enjoys more
than just a composer Credit in a slew of
these films yes the Demonic beasties in
ones films and the larger Conjuring
Universe are portrayed by the same guy
who wrote their killer soundtracks you
can spy bashara in the quick glimpses of
the witch Bathsheba in The Conjuring and
as Malthus the Demonic entity possessing
the titular doll in the Annabelle films
however bashara's portrayal of the
lipstick-based demon in the Insidious
films is his greatest on-screen
contribution to Horror history maybe
it's because he looks like Darth Maul's
cousin or maybe it's his love of Tiny
Tim but this child-killing demon is
undeniably compelling thanks to
bashara's intimidating screen presence
it's hard to pinpoint the best part of
the Return of the Living Dead the
hilariously Bleak 1985 zombie horror
film directed by Dan O'Bannon but in a
film full of nothing but highlights one
goopy lad steals the show Tarman after
the character breaks out of a
military-grade metal drum he stumbles
sloshes and drips his way from the
basement to the ground floor of a
medical supply warehouse
[Music]
while some close-up scenes used a puppet
the longer shots required an actor that
actor ended up being performer and
Puppeteer Alan Troutman who some may
know best for his work on Jim Henson
projects like the Muppets and dinosaurs
Troutman is still bringing creatures to
life having lent his voice in
puppeteering talents to 2016's the
Jungle Book and 2021's Muppets Haunted
Mansion given that Troutman reprized his
role as the goopy ghoul in Return of the
Living Dead Part 2 we're going to assume
that like us the actor has a soft spot
for this rotting hunk of reanimated
Flesh
taking up the role of an already iconic
horror movie monster can be a disturbing
task one that even the best actors
aren't always up to given how excellent
Tim Curry is in the 1990 TV movie
original whoever stepped in is Pennywise
for the big screen 2017 version of it
was going to have some massive red clown
shoes to fill thankfully Bill Skarsgard
was up to the task his performance
differs greatly from Kurds a smart
choice since it's typically best to make
something your own rather than imitate
the original he's uniquely terrifying as
Pennywise more overtly Sinister and
inhuman than Curry's frightening but
undeniably Carnival barker-esque turned
well float down here
Skarsgard comes from a family of Swedish
actors his brother Alexander and father
stellen are also well known after
appearing in a number of Swedish films
he found his break into the American
Market as Roman Godfrey on the Netflix
original program Hemlock Grove for three
seasons since the Show wrapped in 2015
he's also made appearances in atomic
blonde Divergent Allegiant and
assassination Nation as far as horror
goes he also played a featured role in
Barbarian and starred in the Stephen
King inspired Hulu original series
Castle Rock
if you're going into Barbarian for the
first time you might think that the bad
guy is going to be key the suspicious
fellow played by Bill Skarsgard but
writer director Zach kreger has a few
curveballs in store after the secret
beneath the barbaric Airbnb is revealed
Keith Falls victim to the film's True
Villain the mother a large naked
aggressive woman who lives in the tunnel
system below the house Matthew Patrick
Davis a 6-8 theater artist with a sketch
comedy background portrays the mother in
all her glory Davis's on-screen work has
been predominantly on TV shows and short
films making Barbarian an interesting
change of pace in a chat with no Film
School Davis revealed that he booked the
Barbarian gig by sending in a self tape
of himself half naked baby birding a
pickle into an imaginary victim's mouth
when asked about the most challenging
part of his role he responded I think
the night shoots because I mean I was
ass out I was nearly Noob and so it was
cold Davis's efforts paid off though as
his performance helped make Barbarian
one of the biggest surprises of 2022
excuse us for being nostalgic but we get
a little wistful when we think back to
the days when superhero movies could
flirt with a horror genre case in point
1998's blade the first feature film that
sees Wesley Snipes day walking Katana
wielding vampire face off against the
blood-sucking megalomaniac who aims to
unleash the blood God in Blade and
Company's quest to save Humanity the
gang tracks a suspicious human familiar
to a secret vampire Club there they meet
Pearl whose delicate name betrays the
fact that this vampire is a grotesque
piece of Flesh Pearl is a sight to
behold from his ferocious flatulence to
his child-like high-pitched voice the
latter aspect is especially disturbing
in light of director Stephen
norrington's statement on the DVD
commentary that pearls blob-like size is
the result of his endless hunger for
infants
somewhere deep beneath several inches of
foam latex is actor Eric Edwards while
Pearl took multiple crew members to
fully operate it's Edwards who gets the
credit for being entombed in 700 pounds
of latex born in Kansas Edward's other
on-screen performances include
supporting roles in Sergeant Bilco and
Candyman
long before Godzilla became a digital
CGI Goliath actors portrayed the king of
all monsters by stomping around in heavy
sweaty suits through forced perspective
human-sized costumes appeared to be
towering giant capable of easily
crushing cars buildings and historical
landmarks of all the actors tasked with
bringing Kaiju to life one name Reigns
Supreme hauro Nakajima born in 1929
Nakajima began his film career as a
stunt man in Samurai movies and War
films including Akira kurosawa's Seven
Samurai Nakajima then portrayed Godzilla
in 12 consecutive films making him one
of the most beloved and prolific suit
actors in the Kaiju genre in a 2017
video interview with great big story
Nakajima shared that he would observe
animals at the zoo on lunch breaks to
find inspiration for Godzilla's walk he
also explained that because rubber was
in short supply in Japan following World
War II the suit for Godzilla was made
out of mixed concrete in the early days
making it extremely heavy Nakajima
retired from suit acting in 1972 and
passed away from pneumonia complications
in 2017. the filmmaking team behind
2019's Godzilla king of the monsters
dedicated the film to his memory
despite being the universal monster with
the least amount of credits to his name
Gillman is one of the most compelling
creature designs out there debuting in
Jack Arnold's Creature from the Black
Lagoon Gillman's design was until
recently unsung handiwork by Disney
animator Millicent Patrick Gillman is
the perfect balance of Pathos and
practicality without room for words it
fell to the men behind the airtight
molded sponge rubber masks to humanize
the creature's dexterous webbed hands
powerful legs and accusatory gaze while
Ben Chapman who portrayed the Gillman
above water certainly deserves
recognition it's the other man behind
the suit who has inextricably linked
himself with the creature Riku brownen
at 23 Browning worked at Weeki Wachee
Springs a freshwater roadside tourist
attraction some out-of-town Hollywood
types asked him to help with location
scouting and before long they were
asking him to portray the titular
creature in the film's underwater scenes
while Browning ultimately pivoted to
where working behind the camera as a
writer director and stun coordinator he
reprized his role as the underwater
Gillman for two sequels
ever since Gaston laroe published his
Horror Story the Phantom of the Opera in
the early 1900s the story of Eric and
Christine has been adapted dozens of
times but of all the interpretations
from Broadway musicals to Phantom of the
paradise to Phantom of the mall Eric's
Revenge it's the Phantom of the 1925
film that haunts our dreams most played
by the legendary Lon Chaney born on
April Fool's Day 1883 to two deaf
parents Cheney developed a reputation
for being the man of 1000 faces a
self-taught makeup artist and a talented
thespian Cheney's screen presence and
transformative power reverberate through
the decades with undeniable Clarity The
Uncanny Valley defines Cheney's Phantom
his cavernous mouth pit of a nose and
gorged eyes and sunken cheeks almost
seem inhuman when asked about his
methods Cheney told American
cinematographer I'm supposed to have
evolved some magic process of malforming
my features and limbs it's an art not
Magic for the Phantom Cheney contoured
his face and cheekbones flattened his
ears to his skull wore an exaggerated
bald cap that elevated his forehead and
used wires to manipulate the curvature
of his nostrils
Frankenstein's monster is one of the
most recognizable characters in Horror
history and no version of the man-made
man is more iconic than the one in
Universal Pictures series of films in
1931 Universal's Frankenstein hit
theaters featuring Colin Clive as the
doctor and Boris Karloff as his monster
born William Henry Pratt Boris Karloff
got his start on the Canadian stage in
the early 1910s he ultimately made his
way to Hollywood appearing in silent
films where his anglo-indian Heritage
led to castings in Arab indigenous and
Asian roles Karloff racked up 81 credits
before being cast in Frankenstein and
its sequel Bride of Frankenstein Jack
Pierce who had previously worked on
Universal Pictures Dracula conceived the
makeup for Frankenstein's monster of all
the details that make up the monster's
final appearance the rectangular skull
the overhanging brow The Towering height
one of the subtler features was
something of a happy accident as James
El nibar relayed in the monster movies
of Universal Studios Karloff and Pierce
achieved the creatures sunken cheeks by
removing the actor's Dental plate